all right let's go down to jarrod green
river with blake griffin
while marv blake most rebounds in a
playoff game for you with 14 since 2015
18 points you had almost as many threes
as the entire bucks team
what was this saying what were you
saying back in march about people
talking about how bad you were coming
into this nets team
um i'm not even focused on that to be
honest i'm just grateful to be here
the the organization's been unbelievable
fans been unbelievable teammates have
been great
just let me get in my rhythm and do what
i do take us into the huddle 43 seconds
into the game james harden goes down
with a hamstring injury and leaves
what do you guys tell each other
everybody got to step up
you know we got we we've unfortunately
played like that for most of the season
at least since i've been here
um so you know guys came in bruce brown
checked right in
did a great job landry mike james uh we
got guys that you know we'll step up and
take that call and of course you know
kevin and kyrie
do what they do obviously we we are
unclear on james's status
for monday night but but you guys have
played so many games
without a full roster this season in
your limited time here
in a weird way does that prepare you for
moments like monday yeah in a way it
prepares you obviously you never want to
lose a guy like james
um but like you said we've been in this
situation unfortunately so
um you know i trust these guys i trust
everybody
we've had guys step up and make big
plays and you know fill their roles
um all season long since i've been here
so we got to be even better next time
and you're a tough guy tonight too that
was good
sometimes appreciate it blake griffin